Das ist "The Voile of Germany", das ist Nerina Pallot
Und dies ist Clixoom, die Online-Talkshow
Also bitte abonniert, kommentiert und guckt
"The Voice of Germany"
Wie ist die Lage?
Super, danke
Ist es nicht zu viel Arbeit? Ein neues Album und die Arbeit als Coach bei "The Voice of Germany"?
Das Beides ergaenzt sich sehr gut
Es dreht sich beides um Musik, aber das Coaching zu machen ist was ganz anderes
Wenn ich coache liegt der Druck nur bei den Talenten und ich sage ihnen nur "macht dies, macht das"
Aber ich habe auch Spass daran, nebenbei meine eigenen Aufnahmen zu machen
Was machst du lieber?
Das ist eine sehr schwierige Frage
Es sind so unterschiedliche Dinge. Ich habe es wirklich genossen, diesen jungen Talenten Ÿber die letzen Monate zuzusehen wie sie sozusagen aufbluehen
Wir stehen nun recht kurz vor den endgueltigen Entscheidungen, zu welchem Punkt wir mit so vielen anderen Saengern in der Show angekommen sind
Und das ist wirklich aufregend, zu sehen wie die Leute dabei aus sich rauskommen
aber ich liebe es auch, meine eigenen Sachen zu machen und bin sehr gluecklich damit, meine eigenen Songs zu singen
es hat bisher sehr viel Spa§ gemacht, meine Songs dem deutschen Publikum naeher zu bringen
Es ist dein viertes Album
Aber ich glaube es ist erst das zweite, das auch in Deutschland veroeffentlicht wurde
"Year of the Wolf" ist der Titel und "Put your Hands up" ist die Single
Und du bist gespannt, wie es hier in Deutschland mit deiner Musik laeuft?
Ja auf jeden Fall und hab dabei viel Spa§
Ich hab meinen Song letztens im Radio gehoert, das war toll
Es ist immer nett, wenn es weg von Zuhause ist, denn da bin ich das mittlerweile gewohnt
Aber es ist immer toll, wenn man fern der Grenzen was von sich sieht.
Das ist wirklich aufregend
Wenn du deine Musik hoerst, machst du das manchmal vom Standpunkt eines Coaches?
Du meinst nacht dem Motto: "Was soll das, das kannst du besser?"
Ja genau, was soll das? Ist das gut genug?
Das ist seltsam, manchmal realisiere ich es nicht wirklich, dass ich im Fernsehen oder so laufe
Das ist dann so ein: "Ah du kennst den Song! Oh, das bin ich"
Aber wenn du Musik machst, kannst du dich technisch verbessern, aber vor Allem musst du die Dinge einfach laufen lassen
Und dabei an den Stimmen unserer Talente zu arbeiten geht es nicht unbedingt darum, die Techniken zu verbessern, sondern mehr Emotionen reinzubringen
Manchmal muss man grobe Kanten einfach so belassen, wie sie sind
Einige meiner Lieblingssaenger haben keine absolut perfekte Stimme, aber singen mit Charakter und Persšnlichkeit
Und ich denke das ist wirklich wichtig
Ist das dein Hauptanliegen, wenn du coachst?
Ja, ich mšchte was fuehlen, ich will dass es mich beruehrt
Wirklich viele Leute koennen ganz viele Noten singen und Mariah Carey Impressionen darbieten
Aber es ist langweilig
Ja, das ist es. Es sind nur "Techniker"
Aber was ich hoeren mšchte ist die Seele, einzigartige Techniken. Die Toene zu treffen ist natuerlich sehr wichtig
Aber es sollte sein, als ob eine Person zu einer anderen spricht und in ihm Gefuehle ausloest, die man nicht jeden Tag fŸhlt
Das ist aehnlich wie wenn wir Gastgeber unterrichten, dass sie zu einer Person reden
Ja ich denke schon. Es geht darum eine Verbindung aufzubauen
Bei jeder Kunstart. Nicht nur Musik.. Film, Malen.. alles davon geht um Menschen, die andere ueber GefŸhle erreichen und so zu ihnen reden
Das ist auch die Kraft einer gro§artigen Stimme
Und ich denke man merkt das auch im Verlauf der Show. Die Leute die sind jene, welche diese Verbindung mit dem Publikum aufbauen
Und du kannst das trainieren?
Nein, aber ich kann dabei helfen, das es rauskommt
Ich denke, dass jeder es in sich traegt
Selbst der schlechteste Saenger kann einen Moment haben, wo er etwas ehrlich und berŸhrend singen kann
Es geht darum, den Leuten zu helfen das in sich zu finden
Manchmal fehlt es den technisch besten Saengern, dass sie mit ihrer Stimme zu den Leuten sprechen
Es geht also darum, ihnen zu helfen darin aufzubluehen
Geht es auch um den Charakter des Saengers?
Die Persoenlichkeit?
Ja, Persoenlichkeit. Was sagen sie mit ihrer Stimme? Was ist ihre Lebensgeschichte?
Was sind die speziellen Erlebnisse in ihrem Leben, dass sie das BedŸrfnis haben, es den Hoerern mitzuteilen?
Viele Songs macht das aus und wenn du keinen guten Song hast, dann hilft dir auch keine gute Stimme dabei, zu zeigen was du fŸhlst
Es ist ein wenig knifflig
Du kannst so vieles lehren und der Rest dreht sich nur darum, was die Leute von dem, was du gezeigt hast, auch umsetzen
Und ist es nicht auch so, dass die Stimme in den Faellen ein Teil der Seele ist?
Ja absolut. Das ist es ja auch worum es z.B. in Soul Musik geht
Es geht um Schmerz, Melancholie, Sehnsucht.. also das sind auf jeden Fall die Dinge, die mich ansprechen
Als Songwriter mšchte ich meine Emotionen ausdrŸcken
All diese Dinge, die viel Kraft besitzen
Also musst du eine Persoenlichkeit haben, wenn du singen willst
Ja ich denke schon. Es gibt dazu ja auch Leute, die sich dabei viel bewegen und welche, die sehr ruhig sind
Dabei denke ich an Adele, wenn sie "Someone like you" singt
Sie macht nicht viel und steht sehr still da. Und es kommt diese wunderschoene Stimme raus, die einen so sehr beruehrt
Ohne das ganze.. das hat sie nicht noetig
Es muss also nicht immer so viel Drumherum sein, die persšnliche Darbietung kann auch klein und beruehrend sein, aber trotzdem voller Power
Du hast doch sicher viele sehr wichtige Tipps fŸr all jene, die singen wollen
Jeder sollte singen! Es ist so befreiend
Und ich glaube fest an zwei Dinge, die jeder in sich traegt.
Jeder traegt eine Geschichte in sich. Und jeder hat den einen Song in sich, den er gut singen kann und mit dem er sich ausdruecken kann
Auch wenn sie eigentlich nicht singen koennen
Ich kenne niemanden, der Musik nicht mag
Ich kenne niemanden, der nicht fuer sich selbst singt und es genie§t, wenn auch nur im Stillen und selbst wenn sie nichts von ihrer Stimme halten
Ich glaube wirklich, dass das jeder in sich traegt
Also geht unter die Dusche und singt euch alles vom Herzen